We have a voicemail number. That
number is 219. Who? David P.
I don't really know what to make of this
call. It's a caller who says he's obese
and he's called in before and he is obese.
I believe that part that's not the joke. But
he says he identifies as thin. I don't know.
Let's see what you make of this. I don't know
if this is like an anti-trans thing or what.
No joke, Really. No joke. I am an obese male.
But you know what I identify as a. Finn.
Muscular, man. Why? Well, I'm obese.
Compared to who? Compared to a sumo wrestler,
I am pretty darn thin. So yes, I identify as.
A thin, muscular man, even though I am an obese.
Person with metabolic syndrome. Hmm. Why am I
saying all of this? Yeah. What's the difference?
I really don't understand the difference.
Between what? You don't understand the difference
between what and what. A. Between a trans person
expressing their gender. And an obese person
saying they identify as muscular. And then I don't
know. But if there is any greater confusion about
trans people than that voice mail, I certainly
haven't seen it. We've got a great bonus show for
you. There is a new poll which we talked about at
the top of the show from ABC. And we talked about
the top level results. But there are some other
results that are interesting, including one that
shows that under 35% of the population right now
believes Joe Biden has the mental sharpness
required for a second presidential term. We
will discuss that. Will that become a problem?
The Seattle Public Library System has launched a
program to allow teens to access books that have
been banned. We will discuss that. And lastly,
in the wake of this horrifying, horrifying
shooting in Texas, a Texas lawmaker is lobbying
to teach third graders to do first aid for gunshot
wounds so that if there's a shooting and one of
their classmates gets shot. The third graders
who would be between eight and nine years old
would be prepared to administer gunshot related
first aid. This is where we are in Texas, in
the United States. All of those stories and more
when I'm joined by producer Pat on the bonus show.
Oh, the bonus show where you want to make
money and everybody else that makes money
to fund themselves is bad. Super strong bonus
show today. I do think today will make money
on the bonus show. Last week we took a day
off from making money on the bonus show, but
this week we should do it. Also, I have just been
notified that Steve Bannon is now coming after me,
so we're going to review that. I'll probably
have more for about that for you, either on
the bonus show or tomorrow. Join Pacman dot com
is the place to sign up. The history of that.